et je crois que nous sommes des
instruments oui c'est-à-dire les
tableaux sont meilleurs que les peintres
les livres sont meilleurs que les
écrivains et voilà
bonsoir alors la cinquième montagne je
montrais le bouquin voilà une carrière
alors on va d'abord raconter un petit
peu sur beaucoup de choses à dire on n'a
pas tellement de temps on va d'abord
essayer de raconter un petit peu
l'histoire bien que chez vous le la
signification j'irai philosophique soit
plus importante que le que le scénario
mais enfin faut quand même en parler
donc ça se passe en 870 avant
Jésus-Christ et nous avons encore les
mêmes problèmes après 3 millénaires nous
avons encore les mêmes problèmes
politiques c'est le Liban Israël oui
mais parce que moi nous avons encore les
mêmes problèmes philosophiques et
personnel des relations avec les autres
alors c'est l'histoire du prophète Élie
qui quitter Israël et qui va dans une
île qui s'appelle Akbar qui est située
au Liban c'est ça exactement parce que
il y a une reine en Israël qui veut
imposer un Dieu qui est le dieu mâle ça
c'est l'effet historique ça c'est
l'effet historique j'ai décidé de parler
des lectiles des Élie pour parler aussi
des nous-mêmes dans l'essence c'est pas
un commentaire de la Bible
première fois un commentaire sur notre
relation vers l'exil de notre légende
personnelle alors quand il arrive là-bas
il rencontre une femme qui a un fils
dont on dit pas le nom d'ailleurs et le
fils meurt et le premier miracle
d'Hélie c'est de le ressusciter après il
reste là il devient amoureux de cette
femme et le soir où il va faire l'amour
avec elle il y a les Assyriens qui
attaquent la qui attaque la ville tu
racontes
le fils de l'Ave et les reconstruise la
ville c'est ça et puis après lui il est
obligé de retourner en Israël parce que
deuxième miracle il arrive à reconvertir
les Juifs au judaïsme et c'est le fils
de la veuve qui reste chef de Akbar
alors bon c'est un compte philosophique
pour adulte selon la tradition en
colliène
style et syntaxe assez accessible j'ai
un facile à lire parce que c'est pas
votre ambition vous c'est plus ce que
vous dites que de la façon dont vous le
dites c'est toujours la simplicité
c'est bien traduit vous trouvez parce
que très bientôt parce que
oui c'est bien entendu alors bon on
retrouve tout votre thème le sens que
chacun doit donner à sa vie
la légende personnelle qui a été un peu
votre trademark
c'est un livre de quelqu'un qui lutte
contre sa légende nous avons tout notre
légende personnelle l'univers conspire
pour nous aider dans cette situation
mais nous sommes toujours en train
d'essayer parce que soit on pense que
c'est impossible soit on pense que c'est
très difficile ou soit on pense qu'il
n'a pas de problème et normalement même
qu'on a envie notre légende personnelle
les problèmes les trajets j'y arrive oui
c'est ce qui est différent par rapport
il faut dire par rapport à l'alchimiste
c'est que là il y a l'irruption de la
tragé et en fait quand la tragédie doit
pas ce que vous dites c'est que la
tragédie doit pas être prise comme une
punition mais en fait doit permettre à
l'homme de se dépasser c'est c'est
disant le ce qui apparaît dans la
cinquième montagne c'est bien ça
exactement alors on peut dire aussi
comme différence c'est que
l'alchimiste c'est c'est plus la réponse
est en toi et la cinquième montagne
c'est beaucoup plus tourné vers Dieu non
on peut dire ça et on perdure qu'il a
parfois des moments dans notre vie qu'il
faut lutter contre Dieu dans le sens là
c'est à dire j'ai toujours présent j'ai
toujours en train de nous montrer notre
chemin mais il est comme notre Père
comme notre mère il accepte il accepte
les moments qu'il faut faire la
rébellion la scène vers vers lui il
allait chercher qui nous sommes à partir
de ce moment-là plus concerné et plus
conscient de notre propre inquiète dans
la vie c'est ce qui apparaît dans alors
ça se passe toujours autour du bassin
méditerranéen au bouquins pourquoi parce
vous pensez qu'on est plus près de Dieu
quand on est dans le bassin
méditerranéen
forcément une explication
j'ai décidé de faire les utiliser la
Phénicie comme les décors du livre parce
qu'il a fini d'un périodes de 300 ans
sans guerre sans défis du passé
maintenant nous sommes en contrôle de
toutes les situations et ça arrive
toujours chez nous on pense que nous
sommes un contrôle dans une situation il
y a toujours que quelque chose qui vient
pour nous ramener avant alors vous
parlez que l'eau l'âge mur vous a vous a
ramené je dirais vers la vers la
religion hein après de nombreux
errements
propres ces générations des années 70
vous priez trois fois par jour c'est ça
le matin en vous réveillant à 18h et le
soir au coucher est-ce que vous pensez
comme Pascal que finalement pour trouver
Dieu il faut commencer par aller dans
une église et pour prier faut qu'on et
pour croire faut commencer par se mettre
à genoux est-ce que vous croyez à la
force des rites pour trouver la foi que
les rites sont très important par contre
je crois que les sacré est dans les
mondaines dans le quotidiens dans la vie
que nous nous vivons tous les jours ça
c'est mon but parlait toujours
de ça c'est à dire que on peut doit
aller forcément une église pour trouver
Dieu Dieu
pourquoi il faut commencer par faire les
gestes les gens qui vous disent moi je
crois j'irai à l'église quand je
croisais où je ferai des prières quand
je croirais il faut leur dire c'est
l'inverse en fait exactement ce qui fait
que vous pratiquez ces prières
trois fois par jour alors votre
philosophie si on peut parler de
philosophie c'est un peu un syncrétisme
tout à fait d'ailleurs au Brésil le
syncrétisme n'est pas quelque chose de
très étonnant entre une dimension
chrétienne vous avez été élevé par les
par les jésuites une dimension un peu
orientaliste qui vient de de vos voyages
et de de ce qu'on peut appeler les
années babarres
est-ce qu'il y a un peu aussi d'animisme
brésilien dans ces dans ces années Baba
justement vous vous racontez vous aimez
pas trop en parler je sais mais vous
racontez que vous avez été j'ai pratiqué
des choses un peu sataniques vous avez
pratiqué
des sectes j'ai participé aux années 70
des années 70
et qui sont laissés des marques très
forts
j'ai compris très bien les dangers des
sectes maintenant mais par contre je
n'ai pas trouvé la bonne manière de
parler de ça parce que
la façon qu'on parle aujourd'hui c'est
toujours faire la publicité de l'essence
c'est dire ça c'est interdit au moment
qu'on dit que ça c'est interdit que ça
c'est de gérer il y a cette rébellion de
la jeunesse qui nous attire vers le
dangereux alors il faut encore trouver
une moyenne sur la drogue aussi vous
dites chaque fois que je vois une
publicité contre la drogue en fait c'est
toujours la promotion c'est ce que
j'avais dit à ce gars il est fait une
campagne qui disait la drogue c'est de
la merde moi je disais les gens vont pas
payer 1000 francs un gramme de merde
donc la drogue c'est pas de la merde
donc c'est une mauvaise façon voilà vous
êtes tout arrêté vous filmez même pas de
pétard là aujourd'hui même plus des
cigarettes les pétales j'étais les
derniers que j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté
en 80 80
la deuxième la troisième fois après
c'est aussi vous avez eu un ami Pour qui
vous écriviez des chansons qui
s'appelait Raoul sexas qui était un
chanteur très connu un chanteur
contestataire au Brésil à l'époque de la
dictature militaire et tout ça vous avez
il est mort d'une overdose et ça a dû
vous ça a dû vous calmer un peu non
je crois pas que ça c'était la vraie
raison je crois qui est moi-même pendant
l'expérience de la drogue parce qu'on
peut voir les gens mourir avant
il est mort
beaucoup de monde mais c'était quand
même des idoles je dirais que c'était la
conscience de soi-même et bien sûr dans
mon cas je crois que c'était l'aide de
DJ mais je crois que les rapports par
rapport à la drogue c'est très
individuel
il y a un moment qu'on s'est rencontré
ça c'est pas donc vous aujourd'hui vous
conseillez de pas en prendre disons le
clairement
[Musique]
en 68 donc à la grande époque Baba vous
étiez à Paris en 68 non vous étiez vous
étiez dans la dans la dèche comme on dit
donc vous aviez pas d'argent ça nous
fait un malheureusement pas dans les
mains 68 parce que c'était un mythe dans
le monde entier encore un mythe par
contre j'étais à Paris j'ai passé pas
des bons moments là parce qu'il avait un
peu de préjugés vers les hippies j'ai
déjà moi-même je reviens jamais à Paris
et je suis venu de plusieurs fois France
mais au-dessus de la France mais un
moment donné j'étais invité pour pour la
promotion de mon premier livre je suis
venu il s'était complètement différent
c'est pas Paris qui a changé c'est moi
qui a changé alors
68 il y avait le général de Gaulle tout
ça maintenant il s'est passé
alors tout le monde vous parle toujours
de votre succès moi je vais pas vous en
parler parce que vous allez faire plein
d'émissions de télévision et plein
d'émissions de radio tout le monde va
vous dire que vous avez 17000 17
millions de gens qui ont acheté votre
livre etc vous êtes traduit dans 69 pays
ça bon vous allez le dire ailleurs de
pas vous faire des récit la seule chose
dont je voulais parler en revanche c'est
un CD-ROM qui s'appelle Pilgrim qui a
été fait avec infographe donc le
scénario êtes-vous et les dessins sont
de meubus c'est c'est vraiment très très
bien là c'est des Roms ça commence à
devenir des choses comme ça ça va
devenir vraiment intéressant la vie
alors vous êtes on dit de vos bouquins
finalement que vous êtes un peu
l'inventeur du best-seller évangélique
quoi dire que les gens quand ils disent
vos livres ça leur fait du bien un peu
comme du comme du Prozac ou comme comme
la méditation transidentité
transcendantale c'est c'est non je crois
que quand les gens disent mon bouquin si
on demande cette question un lecteur
peut-être va répondre peut-être par le
pose les mêmes questions je ne pose pas
de réponse je pose des questions mais
que ce la question universelle ce sont
des questions qu'on se pose toujours et
qu'on a les embouts il est question sur
le même peut-être et on se sent pas plus
et ça c'est la vous avez trouvé quelque
chose et trouver une longueur d'onde en
fait qui est qui que les gens captent
dans le monde entier c'est extrêmement
rare ça c'est je crois que c'est le
langage symbolique c'est-à-dire je ne
parle pas directement à votre cerveau je
parle à vos cœurs il y avait des
symboles qui sont universels c'est ça
que les Français vont proches des fois
d'ailleurs c'est de pas parler au
cerveau parce que les Français sont très
très intellos c'est connu alors bon j'ai
encore plein de questions à vous poser
mais notamment sur votre façon d'écrire
c'est-à-dire vous écrivez en fait vos
livres assez rapidement celui-là vous
avez mis 23 jours pour l'écrire c'est 15
jours vous vous écrivez la nuit j'écris
la nuit mais par contre je suis un
sainte je pense de la création dans le
bouquin comme la création d'un enfant
alors je suis enceinte pendant 2 ans je
pense je refais je prends pas des notes
parce que je crois que les choses
importantes elles restent et les choses
qui sont pas importants elles sont bon
voilà il a un moment
que le bouquins sont bien il vous énerve
quand on vous dit que vous êtes New Age
parce que vous dites pas du tout moi je
mange bien j'aime bien le bon vin j'aime
bien j'aime bien bien manger donc vous
n'êtes pas puis vous vous avez à midi ou
si vous êtes pas vous n'êtes pas un 5 et
je fume voilà
7 euh j'aime pas mais par contre c'est
totalement de la réalité alors vous
aimez bien venir en France vous avez
pensé vous retirer à un moment dans un
vous avez failli acheter un château dans
le sud de la France vous allez à Lourdes
pour des raisons religieuses évidentes
vous prenez de l'audio donc là vous êtes
vraiment croyant et alors il y a
l'endroit pour vous qui est en France le
centre du monde un peu comme la gare de
Perpignan pour ce genre d'Alice cet
arbre exactement
je veux bien comprendre vous savez qu'il
y en a pas d'explication pendant que les
centres du monde le centre du monde on
s'est rendu compte c'est une ville comme
tous les autres il y a son côté magique
son côté moche alors mais c'est très
bien je me sens chez moi c'est que vous
pourriez être
Isabelle Adjani vous appelle Giulia
Roberts
Warner a quand même racheté les droites
29 millions de dollars bon tout le monde
a envie de vous les les stars Madonna
tout le monde a envie de vous connaître
vous seriez à Hollywood vous serez un
gourou formidable et ce qui est très
sympathique chez vous c'est que pendant
ce temps-là vous êtes en train de jouer
au flipper et de boire des bières
pressions à Tarbes
ça c'est la vraie vie
c'est la vraie vie y aller au café il y
a traversé
une personne totalement normale et il
m'en matière première ce sont les gens
comme moi vous êtes ce qui est très
étonnant le plus étonnant avec vous
c'est ça c'est que vous malgré tout ce
succès planétaire vous soyez rester tout
à fait peut-être parce que le succès est
arrivé tard aussi non c'est prêt
quand ça vient plus tard on est on est
on est déjà un peu un peu formé puis
vous êtes croyant ça aussi ça donne de
l'humilité
il faut toujours être un travail tout à
l'heure mais vous dites le fait d'avoir
vendu ton livre ne peut pas être
attribué à ma capacité vous dites mes
livres sont meilleurs que moi donc
partir du moment où vous avez une
inspiration en me disant extérieur voir
divine c'est normal que ça vous rende
humble oui et tout à fait c'est tout à
fait convaincu que c'est pas ça se passe
pas seulement avec les écrivains mais
les peintres tous les gens qui ont une
façon de s'expresser à travers de l'art
je crois que nous sommes des instruments
oui c'est-à-dire les tableaux sont
meilleurs que les peintres les livres
sont meilleurs que les écrivains et
voilà il s'est toujours comme ça je vous
mets je vous remercie beaucoup je suis
dévoyé ça passe vite on a encore le
temps on aurait pu parler de plein de
choses alors je rappelle le titre du
livre donc c'est la cinquième montagne
Paulo Coelho c'est Anne Carrière voilà
et le CD-ROM
Pilgrim qui est très très bien avec les
dessins de mobilus c'est le et votre
scénario
c'est très bien et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarriture abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu